منذ أن دمرت الصواريخ الروسية
منزلها وقتلت شقيقها ،
كل ما تبقى هو والدتها وحياتها
بدأت تتساقط واحدة تلو الأخرى ،
كانت هناك انفجارات في كل مكان
مقابل المطبخ في المنزل ، كانت
النوافذ والأطر التي
كنا نقف هناك كان يصنعها أخي
علامة الصليب
[موسيقى]
مغطاة بالزبدة لكنه ذهب منزل لودميلا تم تسويته بالارض من السيقان غير المشروعة
خلال معركة
روبيشني التي أصبحت الآن في أيدي
الروس ، كانت قوات بوتين تتجه نحو
الجنوب الشرقي على طول نهر
دونيتسك وجنوبًا من إيسيام
روسيا هدفها المعلن هو الاستيلاء  كل
من دونباس وهذا يشمل
مقاطعات لوهانسك ودونتسك ، يقول حاكم لاانت إن أوكرانيا
يمكن أن تمنع الروس
في الوقت الحالي ،
يقول الصديق إننا بحاجة إلى مدفعية قوية بعيدة المدى
وهذا للأسف ليس
هنا بعد ويمكن أن يغير
الحرب بأكملها تمامًا
بدون  الأسلحة الثقيلة التي
وعدت بها الولايات المتحدة والحلفاء الغربيون الآخرون ،
كما
يقول ، سوف يدمر الروس كل
شيء  مع المدفعية وقذائف الهاون التي قاموا بتدميرها
بالطائرات ، يستخدمون طائرات الهليكوبتر ،
إنهم يمسحون كل شيء من على
وجه الأرض ، لذلك لم يتبق شيء
للتشبث بـ
[الموسيقى
] لأوكرانيا ، هذه معركة وجودية
يتم نقل التعزيزات إلى
الخطوط الأمامية ولكن  ليس هناك ما يشير
إلى وجود أسلحة ثقيلة لازمة لمنع
تقدم
روسي ناهيك عن عكس ذلك ، يقول الطبيب إن لودميلا سيتم نقلها
غربًا لمزيد من العلاج ولكن
مصير والدتها البالغة من العمر 96 عامًا
غير معروف ،
ولا يمكننا ببساطة التعامل مع هذا
العدد الكبير من الجرحى.  مثل هذه الإصابات الخطيرة
، يقول إن
هذه المرأة المسنة ، ضحية القصف الروسي في
ذلك الصباح ، انضمت إلى الجناح
، وفر أكثر من 13 مليون
أوكراني آخر من منازلهم هربًا من مصير لودميلا ،
لقد أحضرت إلى هنا عارية
، ليس لدي أي أموال على الإطلاق ،
ولا وثائق
لا شيء
بعد لها  البقاء على قيد الحياة هو انتصار صغير
على بوتين لأنها لم
تتسول ولم تتعرض للضرب